when you're president of the united
states
you're no ordinary patient helicoptered
to hospital
and given every treatment available but
if the president's doing so well
why is he receiving a drug used on the
most serious cases
professor pete horby uncovered the power
of dexamethasone in helping ventilated
patients to survive
it's now being given to the president in
the very early stages
good evening i think for me the question
is when he started the dexamethasone
if they've just started it today then
that would suggest that his
condition hasn't improved as much as
we've been led to believe but
if they'd started it um very early on
say on friday when he was first in
oxygen
um then it's quite you know plausible
it's now improving considerably
comparisons are being drawn with boris
johnson's condition earlier this year
the prime minister initially upbeat in
isolation
and on the advice of the chief medical
officer i've
taken a test that has come out positive
so
i am working from home i'm self-isolated
but six days later he deteriorated
visibly
three days after that he was admitted to
hospital
then intensive care boris johnson
since described his situation as touch
and go
and said medics saved his life as your
leader what i have to go through
parallels are being drawn with the
president who appeared positive
but not himself in his hospital video
he looked tired he looked worn but
remember when you get covered 19 it's
like a very very bad case of influenza
you feel like you've been wiped out
fatigue is a big issue
muscle aches and pains loss of taste and
smell
fever low grade high grade so he's
undergoing all of that right now so
he he is to be excused for how he looks
i'm just surprised that he actually
spoke from his hospital bed
the president's diagnosis will naturally
receive a higher level of attention from
doctors than the average american
but many of the treatments are still
experimental
and there's a margin for error in
medical circles the treatment of a high
profile patient
is known as vip syndrome where there can
be a tendency to give more medical
care than usual but with covid19 many of
the therapies remain
unproven and there's a danger the
president's
intense treatment plan could have
adverse effects
the president's inability to walk
unaided on occasion
is just one of many instances that have
led to speculation over donald trump's
health
but as he leads the country into a
presidential election from hospital
it's thrust america into a state of
uncertainty
few could have imagined